have I asked you the soundcheck question
about the shortcut key I quorum if I did
it's one favorite okay I ask you that no
no no okay what is your favorite short
cookie I'm partial to have in a windows
D which just minimizes everything I also
like Windows Windows M no hang on now we
have to get a toad eggs and bacon for
breakfast ready shot cookie my favorite
shortcut key my shortcut key favorite
shortcut key interesting control see
there we go chalk that controls ed it's
gotta be that's difficult actually Apple
L are things is the gate grab the
location of a URL from the from a
browser it's a good question oh I like
trying to think of an obscure word now
aren't you no no I'm thinking about one
night not not obscure one that I use a
lot but that not everybody knows about
Corbett which is control are in actually
I don't know if bash is doing it or if
my terminal is doing it I'm not sure if
it's the shell all the time right yeah I
guess it must be bash and it gives you
like a search of your command history
okay so rather than you know you're like
oh I know that I ran a command that was
like this recently and you hit up like
70 times to get to it you can hit
control R and just start typing like the
beginning of the command and it will
fill out the most recent thing you typed
that you know matches that what's your
favorite shortcut key my favorite
shortcut key yeah I don't know how about
a short answer wasn't it when you're
working on your computer control alt
delete it's the only one worth mention
was remembering
just so I can get a little on how loud
you're going to speak what is your
favorite shortcut key Apple F our
platforms that they it finds whatever
I'm fine okay the computers are used on
ten eleven so ma'am there's no such
thing as a shortcut key it's just the
key what's your favorite shortcut key
shortcut key yeah what does that mean
use it like control them via Windows L
what does that do turned off my computer
well locks it favorite shortcut like
control Z I think it might toggle you
know favorite shortcut key the Vulcan
nerve pinch
it does it does they're both the same
oh okay windows D desktop yeah okay okay
yeah yeah day when is M so important
also I also like Windows II which brings
up Explorer so I can go to files it's
there's always a few clicks isn't it
control alright shifted thee what does
that do
it's a reset an old Atari ST there's a
full called reset as opposed to Control
Alt Delete just as a soft reset
I'm sure cookies yeah added hey I use
them all the time this quite useful once
control you was always useful on the BBC
micro that used to delete part of the
line after what was I think well did it
make things invisible I can't remember
now it's been so long ago and I remember
present control you a lot I was asked to
silly Sanjay questions what's favorite
shortcut key Oh control see I've never
thought about I don't know what that
would be shift control on Beebe's was
quite useful as well because it would
slow down the outputted screens as
listing you'd hold down shift and
control it pause and you could release
control and things yeah shortcut keys -
is that what matters foot control
underscore because it's undo in Emacs
favorite the beauty short complete
control C control C because it cancels
things that I've done wrong
control C because it breaks my programs
basically when they're when they've when
they've got into an infinite loop
okay so cannot control C as a copy but
could you know control C as a breaking
out of a loop basically so a few people
say control C so I wonder if that's what
they meant rather than copy cuz mayor's
me thinking seeing V which I use all
time come on a knuckle that's command C
in command V not control C maybe this is
that this is a Apple versus windows
versus Linux divide is shortcut key undo
yeah commander roll
oh I don't know f1 for health maybe f2
when I'm editing
oh my god
most people say what job for breakfast
was computer file so I'm going to say
what's favorite shortcut key ctrl shift
T brings up the web page you just closed
by mistake uh windows add in minimize
minimize all yes yeah okay cool very
cool tell me about your favorite
shortcut key ctrl ctrl Z because I made
a lot of mistakes programming so
pressing controls that is is my friend
okay today you soundcheck question
what's your favorite short cookie
doesn't matter what app doesn't matter
where oh oh oh oh you know I make my own
single letter commands so I have M for
male and F for my little cheesy for
matter and things like that so it's not
exactly a shortcut key but it's can i
abbreviate a command that whose name i
type frequently so i don't have to type
so much favorite shortcut key Oh
controls ed MX definitely meta X it's a
way to enter into a command in Emacs
it's like the programmable shortcut key
what is your favorite shortcut key my
favorite shortcut kay oh heavens it
depends on what system you're on did you
see it what's the escape that's it
escapes the best I was thinking about
that why did shortcut keys come from was
that something that came in with gooeys
or was it something that I think it was
they you used to have to remember all
the control sequences they ASCII low-end
like was it controlled GE gets you a
bell and unless some software gets in
the way and intercepts it says no I'm
not going to bleep the blue before you
but if it on a raw sort of machine the
ASCII low-end is done by using the
control key you know control a is asking
zero I think
yeah good good come at me bro
add something on to it back and pass the
token on and I've got it so I can load
the value in add the value from a
register story back